the jurgen experience i knew i knew i
didn't want to be a person who's just
like taking a percentage of
what other people do i wanted to make
stuff like i wanted to
actually produce and create things
so i knew i wanted to be a writer and
when i first read the stoix
i was just like [ __ ] this is it like
when i read meditations for the first
time
i was 19 i was sitting in my college
apartment
and i was just like not only have i
never read anything like this i've never
even heard of anything like this because
you have
the most powerful man in the world
writing notes to himself
that he never thinks are going to be
published like pretty much every other
book ever written was like a writer
writing
to an audience yeah and meditations is
was never intended to be published he'd
probably be mortified that we even have
it
and so
it was just a kind of philosophy and a
way of thinking that i hadn't heard in
any school
you know in any class from any adult in
my life and i was like i want
to tell people about this
marcus aurelius
one of the more interesting things about
this stuff that he writes is how
relevant it is today like when when you
read it you wouldn't imagine that this
is being written by a man like how many
years ago was that
1900 2000 years ago he's writing in like
the mid
150s 160s a.d
it's
very relevant like the way he writes the
the it's the language is incredibly
familiar it's the same
you know it's
one of the things about um
you know we would always make fun of the
way people talked a long time ago you
know where far now like there's there's
a way of talking that we don't
communicate like today but when marcus
aurelius writes and you like if you read
meditations
it seems very
current well it does depend on the
translation right because like if you
are reading uh and people do this so
i'll recommend marcus rules and they'll
just get what's free on the internet or
whatever um
if you're reading a translation from the
1850s or the 1600s it's going to be in
shakespearean english because oh
interesting right because they're
translating
it into their
particular yeah and so the the right
translation is key do you remember which
one you read i don't
uh i like that there's a gregory hayes
translation for the modern library which
i think is the most like lyrical and
beautiful of all of them that's the one
that i randomly bought on amazon and had
no idea
that
it was going to be the one that would
hit me so were the original ones in
latin
so this is what's crazy about marcus so
marcus lives in rome the romans speak
latin but the philosophical language at
that time was greek so marcus was
writing to himself in greek
so it gives it like when you read those
passages or you listen to them and
you're just like that is one of the most
beautiful things i've ever heard like
there's this one passage where he's like
he talks about like this a stalk of
grain bending low under its own weight
the way olive uh you know falls to the
ground he talks about
the way that when you put bread in the
oven it breaks open on top and we don't
know why that happens it's just this
like beautiful inadvertent act of nature
he's just like writing like a poet like
a great writer
and again he's writing in his non-native
tongue to himself
never expecting anyone would see it how
[ __ ] talent it'd be like finding out
that's like a comedian is like funny in
their diary you're just like wow you're
just naturally that you're not turning
it on or off right it's just like
intuitively part of you hmm
yeah
but i think your point about how it
feels timeless that actually does feel
like a thing i've heard comedians say
which is that like uh
the the specific is universal
i don't think he was trying to talk to
the audience i think he was trying he
was so
unflinchingly honest with himself that
he was touching something
universally human
and that's why because like we should
not be able to relate to his experience
at all right i mean he's literally there
is literally a cult of the emperor that
worshipped the emperor and their spouse
as living deities
and he controlled the largest army in
the world he had unlimited wealth he
could kill
uh or murder or torture or exile anyone
he wanted
um
people cheered him as he walked in the
streets
there's no way we should be able to be
like this passage was talking about
struggling to get out of bed in the
morning and you want to huddle under the
warm covers like how how because i guess
people are people no matter
where you get in life people are people
and not everyone gives in to the
temptations of being in that position
and in his case i think it made him more
more apt to reflect upon his thoughts
and find the source of why he believed
what he believed and why he thought what
he thought yeah he says in in
meditations he says be careful not to be
caesarified
don't be dyed purple because the emperor
wore a purple cloak
and purple purple if now we're just like
the colored purple to get purple it was
this complicated process of different
merchants actually the founder of
stoicism was a merchant in tyrian purple
but like these slaves would smash up sea
slugs or sea snails
dry them on rocks and this dust would
eventually become
like the source of purple wow so and
he's like don't be stained purple so he
was acting like when he becomes emperor
he's like this will change you if you're
not careful and you have to actively
work to make sure that doesn't happen so
he was aware of that
that was
that was the character and gladiator
right he wasn't that marcus israelis was
it based on him roughly
loosely well it's a it's i think one of
the great movies of all time but great
movie
peter o'toole yes he's the one that
joaquin phoenix's character kills at the
beginning
um
and then a lot of the sort of things
that uh maximus says are sort of very
stoic inspired
the irony of that movie
uh is that joaquin phoenix probably
underplays how bad marcus realized his
son was in real life really he really
did get killed by a gladiator he was a
psychopath
uh
immediately
destroys all of marcus's work it's one
of the tragedies of marcus
that
he has a like a pos son
i've always wondered like
how that that seemed like it's joffrey
from game of thrones like that is a very
common thing yeah
why why is that
like
it's an archetype
it is
uh there's another great eastern emperor
cyrus the great and he has a shitty son
too
um
you know it doesn't look like queen
elizabeth's kids are that great
but i what's interesting about marcus is
like
it's weird that he's such this great
man and then most people know nothing
about him
but like marcus's father was not emperor
so
there's there's what they call the five
good emperors so it's basically in all
of roman history there's like five good
emperors and they happen in a row and
they happen in a row because each one
does not have a male heir
so they don't have suns
so in the roman tradition it was much
more common to if you didn't have a son
you would adopt a son
and so the emperor hadrian is old
probably gay does not have any children
and he adopts
uh he he sees something in marcus that
they're very marcus is young but he sort
of starts mentoring this boy they
actually go like hunting together like
he sees something special in this kid
marcus's nickname was verismus or the
truthful one
but he's like just a kid
and
hadrian realizes he's too young to name
him emperor
so he
selects a man named antoninus pius who's
the like the great politician of the
time and makes him emperor on condition
that he adopt marcus aurelius
so marcus and then the thinking was
antoninus pius would live for like five
years and then marcus would be king
and
in fact he lives for like 19 years
so marcus has like a 20-year
apprenticeship in being the emperor
under
a man who like could have killed him who
could have been corrupted by power but
is this incredible example and that's
why at the beginning of meditations
marcus has like a two-page thank you
letter to antoninus his adopted
stepfather oh wow it's [ __ ] crazy and
his son
what was the the deal with the wife
uh marcus's wife yes so marcus's wife
faustina is
i guess it would be
faustina is
antoninus's daughter
so they're not related but that's they
marry the family together marcus loves
her uh they're married a very long time
there are rumors that she's unfaithful
but as far as we know marcus
pays you know no attention to this does
not believe them
um but the tragedy of their marriage is
marcus
loses like seven children before they
reach adulthood
can you imagine that
well that was very common back then
though wasn't it seven's a lot though it
is a lot but isn't that that's uh one of
the reasons why the um
general age that people lived to
was so low back then people think that
people died the your age of expected
death it wasn't that it's just like you
you died in childbirth you died you know
when you were young you died from
infection it wasn't that people didn't
live as long yes like uh there's lots of
old people in rome it's just like
getting getting over like if you made it
to 40 maybe you can make it to 80 right
but like
chances are you weren't gonna make it to
20. yeah that's makes sense i mean
they're all sword fighting and [ __ ]
that's also true i mean just imagine you
could cut your hand and die of an
infection yeah real and obviously
they're [ __ ] in the streets and this
is [ __ ] hard rich people don't have
toilets like they know nothing um
so that's
one of the sort of not rationalizations
but if you're like how does it go so
wrong that this great man
leaves the empire to his son yeah well
he does have a male heir that's a
problem
uh unlike all his predecessors
but
it's it's that
every one of the sons that he wanted to
succeed him died
and that there there's some speculation
that marcus's plan so this is the other
crazy thing about marx if i'm nerding
out you can no please go so uh marcus um
has a stepbrother through this crazy
adoption process he has a stepbrother
and so that he inherits through hadrian
it's a complicated thing but
he has a step brother and so like
we know what kings do to their rivals
like you have to kill them right the
first emperor of rome octavian is julius
caesar's nephew
julius caesar has a half son with
cleopatra
or he has a half brother or whatever he
has a son with cleopatra a son out of
wedlock
and
octavian has two stoic teachers who
instruct him to murder his rival which
he promptly does
uh or have murdered so
the precedent was like you can't have
too many caesars like you can't have
more than one
yeah
uh viable heir um and marcus when he
he's antonine is his favorite
antoninites preps him he
ascends to the throne the first thing
marcus does is he names his brother
lucius ferris co-emperor
which is not only never happened
basically before or since
it is a nod to how the republic was the
republic of rome before it becomes a
monarchy is
led by two consuls like two elected
presidents who serve together as a check
against power
so marcus by naming he can't put it back
to a republic which is the plot of
gladiator um
he can
name himself a co-emperor and the i'd
the thinking is that's what he was
planning to do with his sons but they
all died
so in the movie joaquin phoenix
kind of kills the dad
it kills the dad because marcus does not
no in in the movie not in real life
marcus really knows his son cannot be
king
but in real life
he passes it to him so
and how did marcus aurelius die of the
plague oh wow so that's the other crazy
but again timeless marcus was writing in
what we now call the antonine plague
like they named it after him uh
um
but
it's like a global pandemic it starts in
the east it overwhelms rome
five 10 million people die
they have no way of stopping it so
marcus leads through all of that and
then the the suspicion is that he
catches it at the end
realizes he has it has to send his son
away so he doesn't give it to his son
sets in motion like a series of advisors
who should lead his son
and then his son promptly like gets rid
of all of them and
goes
bad so how does a man like that who's so
introspective and so thoughtful
particularly for the times how does a
man like that have a son that's such a
piece of [ __ ]
i don't know i don't know i mean one
argument is he's a psychopath and
there's sort of nothing you can do
like there's no blame whatsoever
the other argument the more likely one
is like
most great men and we're talking about
history so it's mostly great men but
again queen elizabeth has crappy kids uh
most great men are shitty fathers gandhi
was a bad father
winston churchill was not a good father
why is that
i think they're busy